[Music]
a somber feeling spread throughout the
church as the ceremony began
he had a very intimate loving
relationship with the Lord and he wanted
to share that with the whole world I
think that's going to be his legacy for
the church
her russianers tell us they felt the
need to be present at the mass hosted by
the Diocese of Las Vegas as they were
grieving the death of Pope Benedict from
thousands of miles away I wanted to just
pray for him I and and just know that I
appreciate him for how much she loved
God and His writings and in his own
words and how much he loved Catholics
all around the world the late Pope being
remembered for his transparency when he
stepped down from his role in 2013 the
first pope to resign in 600 years it
shocked me when he resigned but that
showed his humility to understand that
he wasn't able to commit to the job
anymore his decision was made because he
saw his health was failing he said he
didn't have the emotional or the
physical strength to keep on going
during mass Bishop George Leo Thomas
revealed he had the on of meeting the
late Pope a few times throughout his
life I was a bit intimidated I found her
to be very grandfatherly kind very easy
to speak with
during Thursday's Mass he honored Pope
Benedict by wearing a gift he was given
by him he gave me this cross as a
remembrance of our meeting together so
I've worn it really with a lot of
gratitude Victoria Saha 8 News Now
we can also tell you that Pope Benedict
was born in Bavaria Germany and his
birth name was Joseph ratzinger he
passed away in Vatican City on New
Year's Eve at the age of 95.